the death of a Great Hero is just the
start of the tragic turns and black
panther wakanda forever if the movie
left you crying here's what you might
have missed in the explosive Final Act
sure he goes through many challenges as
she takes center stage in the sequel
first she Mourns her brother but after
Neymar and his people the telokons
attacked wakanda and cause the drowning
death of Ramona though Condon Royal has
even more to mourn well let's take a
step back before we get to the third act
early on in the movie shuri convinces
The talocons Who confront her Okoye and
Riri Williams on the bridge in Boston to
take her with them to their hidden ocean
Empire while she's there she bonds with
Namor and hears the story of how his
people came to live underwater Neymar
also gives her a gift a piece of jewelry
that once belonged to his mother and is
made with the leaves of the plant that
granted the talokons the ability to
escape the colonists in Mexico that were
taking their land
my mother told stories about a place
like this a protected land with people
that never had to leave
there are many parallels between wakanda
and talocon one being that they're the
only two places on Earth that seem to
have vibranium when a plant plays a key
role in giving the telecons the power to
abandon the land for the ocean many
viewers May suspect that there is a high
likelihood it may be similar to the
heart-shaped herb that wakanda relied on
to create the Black Panther this turns
out to be true while it takes shuri a
bit longer to put those pieces together
than it might take the audience she
eventually discovers that she only has
to shift a few molecules around in order
to use the telokon's plant to bring the
heart-shaped herb back to life after
shuri successfully fabricates a
heart-shaped Herb in her lab it's time
to test whether or not it's the real
deal while there is no time to do the
traditional ritual associated with
becoming the Black Panther sure he
successfully goes through the
fundamentals of the process in her lab
with the help of Riri and Nakia
it's debatable whether shuri is the best
option for the Black Panther role
considering everything else on the young
Royals plate but Nakia doesn't debate
shuri's choice to take up the mantle or
suggest anyone else would be more suited
for the role at least not right away
earlier in wakanda Forever shuri made it
clear that she does not believe in many
elements of the spiritual or ritualistic
beliefs that many would Condon subscribe
to including the existence of the
ancestral plane despite her insistence
that she only believes in science there
is still a small part of her that hopes
to see her family again in that mystical
realm but when sure he takes the
heart-shaped herb and wakes up there
it's killmonger who turns up to greet
her sure he is just as shocked as the
audience is to see him while shuri may
be unhappy to hear it killmonger
suggested her that out of all the
members of wakanda's royal family she is
the one who's the most like him
I want the throne
killmonger's observations imply that
shuri is becoming obsessed with
vengeance just like killmonger was when
he was alive but at the time they have
their talk shuri doesn't see that to be
true ironically her next move after
denying she's driven by vengeance is to
go to umbaku and tell him all about her
plan for vengeance and Baku initially
seems hesitant to go along with it but
eventually he and sure he agreed to join
forces and take on the telecons
Namor and the telecons initially
revealed themselves because the whole
world is looking for vibranium in the
ocean and they're getting close to
finding it in the telokon's Hidden City
the telokons had successfully kept their
home hidden for hundreds of years and by
any means necessary they'd like to keep
it that way they also Harbor anger at
t'challa for revealing wakanda and its
vibranium to the world which set off a
global race to find more of the
substance as the only location besides
wakanda with vibranium tolokan could
become a target for exploitation with
the stakes high for the talocons the
wakandans are banking on a vibranium
detection device they installed in the
Atlantic Ocean getting their attention
and baiting them out for a fight the
wakandans wait on the surface of the
water wondering if the telecons will
emerge and they don't have to wander for
long it's a lokan soon erupt out of the
water and when they find the wakandans
on the ship poised to attack it leads to
a brutal battle between the one secret
Nations as the tolokans and the
wakandans fight on the ship Riri
Williams patrols the Aaron or Iron Man
armor working to lure Neymar to shuri
for a one-on-one confrontation
Riri and shuries Gambit to capture Namor
is successful and sure he traps name or
under a device she has set up in her
ship that seems to work pretty much like
a really big hair dryer Neymar has
already demonstrated great power as a
fighter with Land Air and sea
capabilities with mutations that enable
him to be remarkably Adept at swimming
fighting and flying but his power seems
to rely on the presence of water so the
wakandans reason that if he sufficiently
dehydrated he'll be significantly
weakened which will make him much easier
to fight on paper dehydration sounds
like an absurd weakness for a superhero
when you think about it it's kind of a
weakness for everybody but despite how
silly it may sound the movie treats this
scene and Neymar's Valiant attempts to
fight against shuri's big dehydrator
with the utmost seriousness Namor is a
determined fighter so even though he is
weakened by the drying device he's still
able to use his spear to escape the
machine in an effort to maintain her
fighting Advantage shuri commands her
ship to fly to the desert slightly
Inland from the water as a touchdown
shuri Dons her black panther suit and
she and Namor begin to fight
meanwhile in the ocean the wakandans are
preparing to retreat however as they do
a group of telokons approaches their
ship riding two humpback whales they
throw a massive number of small bombs at
the ship leading to panic and mass
casualties despite the destruction the
wakandans abandoned their Retreat and
the fighting between the wakandans and
the telecons becomes more intense than
ever while the wakandan's losses are no
doubt terrible there is still some
Redemption to be had in this battle
Okoye takes on a Tuma for the second
time looking for Redemption after he
bested her with ruthless Precision
during their earlier fight in Boston
although her failure to save shuri from
being taken by the telokons in that
confrontation led to a dismissal from
the Dora melange she comes back for her
rematch wearing the Midnight Angel suit
shuri created for her whether it's the
suits or simply her determination to
prove herself Okoye manages the best of
Tuma the second time around elsewhere
Riri is taking on Neymar for the second
time after the talocon warrior knocked
her out on the bridge in Boston and just
like Okoye this time Riri is Victorious
back in the desert shuri appears to have
the upper hand against a weak and Namor
that is until Namor recovers his Spear
and stabs shuri in the abdomen stopping
her in her tracks Neymar is somewhat
solemn about his victory informing her
that things could have been different
between them and their two Nations
clearly Neymar is still of the opinion
that wakanda and telokan should work
together to take on the whole world
mutually protecting both their countries
and their vibranium
unfortunately shuri is in no state to
debate anymore now as she seems like she
is very likely to be dying from his
attack as she stands there struggling
she flashes back to her encounter with
killmonger on the ancestral plane where
he asked her if she would be Noble like
t'challa or take care of business like
him this memory seems to give her the
strength she needs to jump back into
action her Checkmate move is a massive
explosion that injures name or badly
while she remains protected by her black
panther suit shuri then stands over
Neymar apparently poised to kill him yet
as she looks down on him with her weapon
ready to deliver a fatal blow she starts
to remember everything that she's been
through over the past year including
t'challa's death the devastation of
wakanda by telokon and her mother's
death finally she sees her mother who
urges her toward peace
show them
who we are sure he stops the attack on
Namor and tells him that Vengeance has
consumed both of them but it must not
consume their people Neymar surrenders
to her and sure he promises to keep
tolokan's secret from the rest of the
world
churian Namor fly to the side of the
battle between their peoples and stop
the fighting declaring wakanda into
lokan to have a truce with a central
conflict in the movie put to rest the
characters start to return to their
normal lives in wakanda they replant the
heart-shaped herb that shuri
reconstructed shuri sends Riri home
without the Iron Heart suit she created
for her but she does not leave
empty-handed Cherry has also fixed the
car Riri was working on in Boston which
Riri explains belonging to her father
then there is a gathering of all of
wakanda that fans of the first Black
Panther movie will recognize as the
ritual t'challa participated in to
officially become wakanda's ruler this
time the ceremony is meant for shuri but
when a ship flies in and shuri is
introduced instead of the princess
emerging it's in Baku who appears as he
jumps from the ship he announces that he
wishes to challenge shuri for the throne
in the ocean emura confronts Neymar
about surrendering to wakanda a move she
is none too pleased with but Neymar
reassures her that the surface world
will once again come for wakanda and
when it does wakanda will have no choice
but to turn to them apparently Neymar
still believes the world is eventually
going to attack wakanda for its
vibranium and he is prepared to buy it
his time until that happens the truce
may be shakier than it first appeared
meanwhile in America Okoye rescues agent
Ross from CIA custody gleefully
declaring she has never seen a colonizer
in chains before perhaps okoye's actions
were a bit of a thank you after Ross was
arrested for leaking secrets to her and
shuri earlier in the film one way or
another it seems the alliance between
Ross and wakanda is set to grow even
deeper than it already was
instead of the ceremony in wakanda that
she was expected to attend shuri is
instead found in Haiti where Nikia now
lives right before the credits roll sure
he goes to the beach by herself and
Burns t'challa's Funeral robes in a fire
on the beach this is a ritual Ramona
tried to perform with shuri earlier in
the movie before they were interrupted
by Namor a mid-credits scene then picks
back up on the beach a shirt he sits in
the sand looking out toward the water
Nakia approaches her with a child at her
side named Tucson Nakia introduces the
child to his aunt shuri who realizes was
surprised that she's meeting t'challa's
son Nakia explains that t'challa and
Ramona knew about Tucson but beyond them
the child was the secret when t'challa
learned he was dying he prepared his son
and asked the Kia to keep him away from
the funeral while these were clearly
acts of love it is hard not to wonder if
keeping Tucson away from wakanda was the
right idea on the other hand the child
seems fairly content when he tells Shari
that Toussaint is his Haitian name but
his real name is t'challa JR a
revelation that indicates that t'challa
and Ikea despite moving him so far away
in secret ultimately do want to
acknowledge that the child is the true
heir to wakanda's throne what that could
mean for leadership in wakanda isn't
clear though because after shuri and
t'challa Junior's brief exchange the
credits continue and black panther
wakanda forever comes to an end with a
promise that black panther will return
[Music]